Speaker 1: There were three notable Trump
events over the weekend, and I want to go
over them with you.
Joe Biden expected to announce his reelection
this week and have an event of his own, which
we will, of course, cover live and then have
clips for you when it happens.
Let's start with the first of three Trump
events.
Trump did what's called the Nell Cowboys interview.
People leave me voicemails and they think
it's the Milk Boys.
It's the Nell boys.
Okay.
Very important to understand.
Completely deranged and hilarious.
This was Trump, I guess, trying to be kind
of like an everyday guy of sorts or something
like that.
But one of the really interesting things is
that Trump, for all of his praise of Florida
and DeSantis during the pandemic, he's now
retroactively talking about how terribly things
went in Florida during the pandemic.
Now, as is often the case, Florida is the
epitome of mediocrity.
Florida wasn't disastrously bad during the
pandemic, and it certainly wasn't very good.
They had a pretty high death rate, but certainly
not the highest death rate.
So anyway, Trump now is doing this whole thing
where DeSantis proves that he's bad because
Florida was bad during the pandemic.
Speaker 5: Why do you think he's what, like
besides that?
Because he's done a pretty good job with Florida.
You agree?
Why do you think you're a better choice than
dissenters?
Speaker 2: Well, actually, if you look at
the numbers, he didn't do a great job.
If you take a look at the numbers, he's very
high on crime, very high.
Speaker 1: Rated.
He's high on crime.
He's smoking it daily.
Speaker 2: It's up almost at the top.
He I think he gets good publicity, although
now people are starting because I'm putting
out the COVID numbers.
He didn't do well in COVID.
He had more deaths.
And almost every country in Florida, I hate
to say it because Florida's my state, but
he had he did not have he did not do well.
It's it's really it's very interesting.
I don't want to knock anybody.
But the thing he did well on is public relations,
because the numbers weren't what they pretended
to be.
With all of that being said, when you help
somebody, I believe in loyalty.
You just don't do what he did.
Now he's out campaigning.
I assume he's going to run.
But I think the numbers are so bad now that
a lot of people are assuming that he won't
run.
Speaker 5: And would you consider him like
to be your running mate?
Speaker 2: I don't I don't see it.
I mean, I don't see a lot we have a lot of
great people in the Republican Party.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Increasingly, it is being suggested that Trump
is going to pick a completely insane woman
rather than a completely insane man to run
with him.
And Ron DeSantis is.
So, listen, the truth about Florida and COVID,
as with most of these things, that for a while
they'll praise someone and then they'll attack
someone for the exact same thing.
The truth about COVID is like Florida wasn't
great, and Ron DeSantis made some pretty boneheaded
moves when it came to COVID and Florida and
Florida, in part thanks to being a warmer
state where people spend a lot more time outside,
it probably mitigated some of the disastrous
effect of the DeSantis COVID policy.
But Florida was nothing to write home about.
It's not an outlier when it comes to COVID
one way or the other, but Trump is making
a big deal out of it now.
The topic of dictators came up during the
interview with the Nell Cowboys, and Trump,
of course, praised dictator Kim Jong un and
just generally seems really impressed with
dictators.
This will come up later in our segment on
the show about Trump's interview last night
with Fox News's Mark Levin about Trump's infatuation
with dictators.
But here's just a little preview.
Trump talking about Kim Jong un.
Speaker 5: Another thing I want to ask to
something historic that I'm always amazed
by what you did is how you got along so well
with all these world leaders, especially Kim
Jong un.
Speaker 1: Now, let me I have to posit right
there, and I'm not going to pause it again
during this segment, this quote, this shows
how the network boys don't know anything.
If you know anything about the history of
American presidential relationships with North
Korean leaders, it's not a surprise that once
an American president agrees to meet with
a North Korean leader if he is impressed by
the apparent charisma of that North Korean
leader, they're going to say, hey, I did something
great.
It's amazing that I've been able to maintain
this good relation now in person with this
leader.
North Korean leaders going back to Kim Il
Sung have been interested and wanted to meet
with American presidents and get the exact
sorts of photo ops that they got from Trump
because it's good for them, it's good for
propaganda value, it's good for showing, look,
we're respected the way American presidents
are.
And the reason that these meetings haven't
taken place the way Trump did is with Kim
Jong un in the past is that American presidents
saw the propaganda value to the North Korean
leadership of such a meeting.
And so they didn't want to do those meetings
without preconditions, pre negotiations that
the North Korean leaders.
Never agreed to Trump.
And and these now cowboys being impressed
with the way they were able to cordially meet
with Kim Jong un.
It goes to their naivete about how North Korea
works.
All right.
Let's listen to the rest of this.
Speaker 2: What I did.
Speaker 5: What was he like as like a person
Because he's like such a mysterious and kind
of like figure.
No one knows what he's like.
What is Kim Jong un?
Well, first.
Speaker 2: Of all, he's very smart and he's
very cunning and he's very ruthless.
Speaker 1: How so?
Speaker 5: Like, how What makes him so smart?
Speaker 2: Well, I guess genetically he was
born pretty smart.
Speaker 1: He just it was bred into him.
They bred in the intelligence the way we want
to breed math skills.
Well, who was it?
Candace Owens, who said we need to breed math
skills into our kids in order to be better
than the South Koreans, I guess.
Speaker 2: Don't forget, he took over a country
at 23, and even though he was sort of like
it was like an inheritance.
This is a country with smart, energetic people.
He, from a very early start, got it.
He took it over from his father, but very
young.
And you had generals and you had all of these
people and armies and know every.
And he gained control.
And let me tell you, he is the boss of that
country.
But I got to know him very well.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Might be interesting to lead with an absolutely
brutal dictator oppressing in a completely
almost beyond words way about 25% of the North
Korean population oppressing more softly another
50% of the population and creating this kind
of over class of his sycophants and suck ups
with another 20.
But, you know, that's where I would start.
Rather than cunning and amazing and incredible
what he was able to do.
Okay.
Only someone who understands no history could
ask that question or answer it in that way.
Trump at another point when talking about
this J. Six song, says he didn't even know
what Billboard was or what iTunes is until,
I guess, a few weeks ago.
Speaker 2: And it was done by the J six prisoners
who have been treated horribly.
When you see the way Antifa got treated, Antifa
did such destruction and cause death and these
people were treated horribly.
And that's what I do.
A voiceover I did basically a voiceover of
the song, and it went to number one on Billboard
on iTunes.
These are names I never even heard of three
weeks ago, But iTunes number one, Billboard
number one, Billboard's like a big deal because
that's sort of like, Oh, you would tell me.
But as you know, what you know is Donald J.
Trump and the J. Six.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Interestingly, iTunes has actually been shut
down years ago.
It's now Apple Music and then Apple Podcasts
and Apple TV.
So one of the funniest things is Trump says
he didn't learn about iTunes until a few weeks
ago.
It actually was shut down years ago.
So it's it's all just a mess.
And then lastly, during this interview with
the Network Boys, Trump says if he was leading
a South American country, he would just dump
the prison population and the, quote, men's
mental institution population right into the
United States, which he claims they are doing,
which they are not.
Speaker 2: Who wants an open border where
people from mental institutions are being
dumped into the U.S., where people from prisons,
where entire prison populations of countries
are being.
And I do the same thing.
If I was the president of a South American
or not, only South America, they're coming
from all over the world.
Speaker 1: He may not know the names of any
South American countries, which is why he
paused like that.
Speaker 2: They're dumping their prison population
into the United States of America.
They're dumping their people from mental institutions
and words that aren't used anymore.
Insane asylum.
Do you ever.
You're too young.
That's where Silence of the Lambs, Of course.
Speaker 1: That's the lamb I hear.
You know, it's.
It's Silence of the Lambs, right Where.
Speaker 2: Silence of the Lambs happens to
be.
That's what's is represented.
But insane asylums.
These are these are seriously sick.
They are being dumped into the United States
of America.
Speaker 1: Huge, massive dumps.
They're not happening, though.
That's.
That's untrue.
It isn't happening.
The most depressing thing about the Nell Cowboys
interview to me is that these guys, these
now cowboys basically seem like suck ups to
Trump.
They don't know anything about history.
Their questions, they can't even form an actual
critical question because they lack such knowledge.
And that's why Trump is so impressed with
them.
Trump walks in and everybody's throwing bouquets
at each other and they got Trump a gift.
Whereas if Trump appeared on a single podcast
that could actually assemble a logical interview,
you would have a very different outcome that
I can assure you.